hundreds of employee emails and text
released by Boeing to Congress paint a
deeply disturbing picture of how the
company sought to mislead federal
regulators about the safety of its
embattled 737 max jetliner the max's you
know was grounded for nearly ten months
after a flaw in the plane's software was
a key factor to two crashes that killed
346 people Kris Van Cleave has been
following this story and joins us once
again from Washington Chris these
documents very disturbing what's in them
well good morning in the messages Boeing
employees talk about deceiving the FAA
mocking regulations even appearing to
joke about the potential flaws in the
737 max now all of this is playing out
before the two deadly Macs crashes
Boeing calls the exchanges that happened
between 2013 and 2018 in completely
unacceptable and says some of those
employees will face disciplinary action
in one from 2018 a Boeing pilot says I
still haven't been forgiven by God for
the covering up I did last year can't do
it one more time in another exchange an
employee asks would you put your family
on a max simulator trained aircraft
I wouldn't other messages raised
complaints about the plane itself one
said this airplane is designed by clowns
who in turn are supervised by monkeys
these documents illustrate the internal
pressure felt at the company to have the
max certified without having pilots go
through three hours simulator training
but in a move that surprised some at the
FAA on Tuesday Boeing announced it would
recommend additional simulator training
for pilots as regulators work to clear
the max to fly again the messages were
given to Congress in December House
Transportation Chairman Peter DeFazio
calls them quote incredibly damning the
FAA maintains it has a rigorous process
for qualifying flight simulators and
certifying aircraft Tony and Boeing is
apologizing they're probably wondering
how many more apologies they're gonna
have to give related to the max Chris
thank you very much
you